On behalf of the Emory
Libraries and the Stuart A. Rose
Manuscript, Archives,
and Rare Book Library,
I'm thrilled to welcome you to
tonight's special event, Sister
Writers: An Evening with
Pearl Cleage and Tayari Jones.
Round of applause is in order.
My name is Jennifer Meehan.
I serve as interim director
of the Rose Library.
Our mission in the Rose Library
is to collect and connect
stories of human experience
to promote access and learning
and to create
opportunities for dialogue
for all wise hearts
who seek knowledge.
As part of our mission we offer
programs such as this one,
and we put on exhibits to
explore and share stories
from the collections
such as the exhibit which
inspired this program.
She Gathers Me: Networks
Among Black Women Writers
curated by Gabrielle Dudley,
instruction archivist
in the rose library and
our moderator here tonight.
Another round of applause.
She Gathers Me explores the
networks among black women
writers through an examination
of the connections found
within their letters, journals,
calendars, and photographs.
One story explored
in the exhibit
is the intimate connection
between our guests
this evening.
New York Times bestselling
author and new Emory faculty
member, Tayari Jones--
[APPLAUSE]
We're just going
to keep applauding
--and nationally recognized
playwright, poet, novelist,
and social activist,
Pearl Cleage,
whose papers are amongst the
Rose Libraries collections.
[APPLAUSE]
In discussion together
they will share
more of the story of
their intimate connection
of mentorship and writing.
We hope that you will visit
this exhibit which is currently
on display in the Rose Library
now through next Wednesday,
October 3.
So its final days.
Just a few logistical notes
before we start our discussion.
I want to let everyone know
that the event is being streamed
through Facebook Live on the
Emory University website,
and we're also
videotaping the event.
Following the
discussion there will
be time for questions
from the audience.
If you wish to ask
a question we're
going to ask that you line
up at one of the two mics
that will be set up for you.
And then following the
program the authors books
will be for sale
and the two authors
will be signing
books in the foyer
and we'll ask you
to line for that
at the back of the ballroom.
So without further
ado, it's my pleasure
to introduce Gabrielle Dudley.
[APPLAUSE]
Gabrielle M. Dudley is
the instruction archivist
in the Stewart A. Rose
Manuscript, Archives,
and Rare Book Library.
In this role she
partners with faculty
to develop courses and research
assignments that draw heavily
from the materials
in the Rose Library.
Gabrielle recently facilitated
a grant funded project
that use the papers
of black women writers
to teach archives research
skills to students
at Emory and Spelman College.
And she's curator of the
exhibit She Gathers Me:
Networks Among
Black Women Writers.
Gabrielle, turning
it over to you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much Jennifer
for that great introduction.
I want to thank you both so much
for being here this evening.
I'm really excited to have
the two of you on this stage
here at Emory tonight.
This conversation,
it's really been
something that's been
years in the making for me.
And I'll give you a sort
of a brief story about why.
So in preparation for the
She Gathers Me exhibition,
I knew that most people's
interactions with writers,
specifically black
women writers,
would probably come from
their published works.
But it was actually through
looking in your papers
Pearl that I began to see how
looking at your correspondence
you had extensive relationships
with other black women writers,
and of course,
people like Tayari.
And this really sparked
this idea of exploration
between writing networks
with black women.
Then I became curious
about whether black women
writers in Rose Library
also had these relationships
visible within their
personal papers.
And they actually did.
So it was basically you
and Tayari's relationship
that was a springboard for a
personal and professional sort
of endeavor for me.
So thank you both for that.
Could you start by telling us
a bit about how the two of you
met and how your
relationship has
grown over the years for those
that might not be familiar?
Do you want me to start?
I think you may
should start to say
that we met before
we met because Pearl
was a friend of my parents.
And so when I met Pearl she was
the first writer I ever met.
I love to say I met a writer
and she was my teacher.
And I mentioned her to
my dad and he called her.
He said, young Pearl?
[LAUGHTER]
Reverend Cleage's from Detroit?
So we were connected
before we were connected.
But she was teaching
creative writing class
at Spelman College.
We're both graduates of Spelman,
and I wanted to take the class.
I wasn't old enough to
take the class because you
had to be I think a junior or
something to take the class,
but I always wanted
to be a writer.
I had never seen a writer
and there was a writer,
and I wanted to take a class.
So I weighed my
options and I decided
that I had no choice but to--
I think forge is too
strong of a word for it.
[LAUGHTER]
--to approximate the
signature of my advisor--
[LAUGHTER]
--allowing me to take the class.
And I will let Pearl
take over from here.
I don't even think I ever knew
that that was a forced thing.
I didn't want to make an
accessory after the fact.
I hadn't been teaching
long and I really
didn't know what I was doing.
So that I had way too
many people in that class.
Wasn't your class a huge class
where I had so many people?
So many.
Because whoever came to
me and said, oh, I really
want to take your
class, I would say OK.
So I mean it was ridiculous.
But most of the
young women in there
they may have read something
that I had written,
or they kind of had a
vague idea that they
were interested in writing.
But then I had one student
who was so determined
to be a writer.
She was so serious
about it so that when
we would have this huge class--
and there were a lot of people
in the class who
were so not serious
and they would try to divert
attention as students will
do when they haven't
done the writing
they were supposed to do.
So they want you to talk
all over here and all that.
And that used to
drive Tayari crazy.
So she came up to me
after class one day
and said these girls
are not serious.
You should make them be quiet.
I'm trying to learn from
you and they won't be quiet.
They won't be quiet.
I said, OK, here's
what we're going to do.
You're going to be a writer.
They're not going to be writers.
So what you need
to do is to come by
and see me a couple of
times a week by yourself.
We'll talk about your writing.
I'll give you assignments
and we'll do this between us
because I'm already a writer and
I know you're going to be one.
And she was so relieved
that she wasn't
going to have to suffer through
all of the non serious writers.
But it was really a
wonderful thing for me
as a young teacher to
come across a student who
was so determined to know
what it took to be a writer.
So I had the
wonderful experience
of being pushed by a
student to figure out a way
to effectively communicate what
I knew because she so wanted
to know so that it was
a wonderful teaching
experience for me.
And we got to be friends.
After she was no longer my
student, we kept in touch.
I was publishing a magazine
called Catalyst at the time.
And I'm always proud that
I'm the first person who
published a short story
and sent her a check.
Sent her a check.
She sent me a check for $100.
I was like, what should I do?
Should I invest it?
How can I manage all this money?
But that was very important to
me as an editor of a magazine
because it was funded
by Fulton County,
and I appreciate it to this day
that they invested in the arts
in that way.
But I wanted to be clear that
part of the money that they
were giving me was going to be
used to pay writers because I
don't care if it's a little
tiny three sentence poem,
you need to get paid
for it if you wrote it.
If it's a short story,
you should get paid for it
so that we always pay writers.
Exactly.
So that, it was
really wonderful.
And then once she went
off to graduate school
we stayed in touch,
which is probably
where some of those
letters came from.
A lot of the letters.
I'm out here in the
middle of the prairie.
What am I doing here?
Why did I decide to do this?
But always writing.
Always writing.
I'd love those letters because
there's all of the personal,
I'm a young woman away from
home in southwest Atlanta
for the first time
and this environment
does not have a lot of
people that look like me.
What should I do?
I feel crazy, all of that.
And then under that was, and
this is what I'm writing.
This is what I'm working on.
This is what I'm
trying to figure out.
And that's the two
tracks that are always
going to be the two tracks
you're on I think as a writer.
One is, my life is
driving me crazy.
What am I going to do?
And the other one is,
what am I writing and why?
So that she was already
asking those questions.
And the more we talked
and the more she'd
became the writer that she was
going to be, the closer we got.
So we had the
wonderful experience
of realizing we were friends.
It's been 30 years.
There you go.
I was a kid.
I was like 16.
But when you were talking
about how you paid the writers,
you paid me that
$100, but you also
told me something about
money and writing.
And you said you want to
be paid for your writing,
but you don't want to
have to write for money.
And I've always kept that.
I don't want to have
to write for money
has been as or even more
important to me than making
sure I get paid.
Although I do want to get
paid, don't get me wrong.
But this idea of you're
being paid for your work,
but you're not selling it.
And that was really important.
I mean there are just so many
things over all these years
advice that you've given me
because I mean when you said
that about these connections
between black women writers,
our numbers are few.
You're having an
experience that's
so unique and very
few people have had it
and black women writers tend to
have also really short careers.
So there are very
few people who've
been there long enough that
are ahead of you to give you
the pass advice back.
So I really treasure this.
I was on the internet and I
was asking writers about advice
they've gotten
from their mentors
and I was surprised at
how many people were
saying I never had a mentor.
I don't even know how I would be
doing this without the example.
I mean, you talked about how
you helped me with my writing,
but you also modeled for me
what a writing life of purpose
could look like.
And it helped me when I became
a writer and I moved to New York
and everyone was
like living and dying
by who's nominated
for what awards, who's
in what magazines.
I always say Pearl never
trained me up on awards.
We never ever said
the word awards.
We never talked about them.
So we never talked about
who's getting reviewed where.
We talked about the books
and the authors we love
and why we love
them, but we never
talked about that other stuff.
So it wasn't imprinted on me
when I was a young writer.
So when I got to be an
older writer in that world
it didn't turn my head.
Wow.
Excellent.
One of the other
things you were talking
about those kinds
of networks and that
when you started looking
you saw there's so many
of the black women writers
had those networks.
And since I'm of
a generation older
than you, that I remember
when I'd started writing
and how helpful it was to me
to have the women writers who
were a generation
or so older than me
to be supportive of what I did.
All of them were--
I remember going to a party at
Dr. Richard Long's house who
used to be here at Emory
who I miss every single day.
And it was one of
those great parties
that Richard Long used
to have where it was just
all the people that
you loved were there
and the food was good
and there were books
that you want to
steal in his library.
And it was just wonderful.
And he was having a
party for Maya Angelou.
And so I got to the house
and I didn't know her.
I knew of course of her and who
she was, but I didn't know her.
And I came to Richard's house
and she was in the kitchen.
She was cooking.
And I was like so
nervous about meeting her
that I was trying to
hide in the living room
because she was in the kitchen.
And he came out and
said to me, Maya
will see you in the kitchen now.
[LAUGHTER]
So I was like OK.
So I went to see
Maya and she was
standing over the
pots and everything
and she looked up at me and
said, ah, there you are.
How is your work going?
And I've never forgotten it
because she actually wanted
to talk to me about my writing.
She took it seriously.
And I'm sitting there
having the conversation
and my brain is
saying you're talking
to Maya about your writing.
You're talking to Maya
about your writing
because it means everything
to have the writers that you
admire, to have
Alice Walker tell me
that she thought something I had
written was wonderful to have.
Bebe Moore Campbell, who
is my contemporary who
has passed away now, asked
me the critical question.
When I turned in my
manuscript for my first novel
and my editor who kept it for
like six months, eight months,
and then finally called me and
said this is the worst book
I've ever read.
We can't possibly publish it.
And don't send it to anyone
else because if someone else
publishes it you will
never publish another book
as long as you live.
And I said wow, I
kind of like the book.
I thought the book was a
little better than that.
So I called Bebe and told
her this heartbreaking news
that the woman said
this was the worst book.
The characters are unlikeable.
Everything you wouldn't
want to hear as a writer.
And Bebe let me kind
of moan on for a while,
and then she said what
did your agent say?
And I said I don't
have an agent.
I didn't know anybody who was
a writer who had an agent.
The writers I knew
self published,
had little old Volkswagen's
and went around to communities
and read their poems.
So she was asking me who
was doing business for me,
and I didn't understand
that you needed somebody
to do business for me.
So she sent several black
women to me who were agents.
I called the first one.
She wasn't there.
I called the second and she
became my agent for years.
But that was why when it
came time to talk to you,
I could talk to you about
doing business for yourself
and finding someone
who could look out
for you because someone
had done that for me.
And it was so important
to me because it
made all the difference.
I mean, the agent told me how
to get the manuscript back,
how she would get
someone else to give me
an advance so I could pay
back that advance, which
I had spent of course.
So that they sold
the book in one day
and it became what looks like
crazy on an ordinary day.
[APPLAUSE]
So I always tell
young writers that
don't believe because
one person in Manhattan
tells you the book
sucks, don't believe it
because that book did
so well and people still
stop me in the
publics and tell me
how much they love that book.
It's a great book.
Thank you.
But I wanted to take
all those things
that I had learned from
the generation above me
and from my
contemporaries, and then
to find a younger writer who
really was serious about it.
It allowed me to kind of say,
OK, now I'm going to tell you.
Now you've got to
tell somebody else
and then they'll
tell somebody else.
We were just in the car today
and she said put your agent on.
That's right.
Just like about 20 minutes
ago that was her advice.
Because I'm protective.
I think that's part of it
that we protect each other
as black women writers.
When I've got an
opening I write plays.
So when I have an opening
and I'm going crazy
I know my sister
writers will know
to say it's going to be fine.
It's going to be wonderful.
It's going to be fine.
And when I saw the schedule
for Tayari's book tour,
I was really afraid
for her because it
was every day somewhere else.
And I said you can do this.
I will send you a text every
morning and say good morning.
Everything's going to be great.
And I did for the whole tour.
And sometimes she'd be like I
know everything is going great,
and sometimes she'd be like,
oh, everything is terrible.
I'm far from home.
But the knowing that you've got
somebody who's got eyes on you
and who wants you to do well who
is not pulling against you, who
is not saying if her
book does well my book
isn't going to do well.
If she gets that job
I won't get that job.
Black women writers that I've
known don't tend to do that.
We tend to say there's
a job open over here.
I think Marie should take it.
I think this one
should be it and then
we help each other move forward.
[APPLAUSE]
When you think
that in generations
past when black women were
not under consideration
for major awards
and other things
that people looked as
landmarks of success.
It's only in very recent
history that black women
have been in the
running for things
that because of this we made
our own ways of assessing
our value that was
about not impressing,
or just communicating with
each other in a different kind
of way.
That if you didn't have support
from other black women writers,
you didn't have anything.
We were our world.
I think that now
things have changed
more because of
more opportunities
and things that people--
sometimes I feel almost like the
connection between black women
writers and black
writers because I
think it's like
with a lot of things
that because it's not considered
a necessity in the same way,
that the connection
is not as it once was.
I think that's true, and
I think it's a shame.
I think it's kind of like
when integration came,
people left all
the black resorts
and left all the
black businesses
and went elsewhere
because we could.
Rather than adding on, we
figured we had to give up one.
And I think that there is a
much greater willingness now
to kind of step on and
step over each other
because we want to be on
the New York Times list.
We want to get this award.
We want to get this and that.
And it's a very different
way of looking at the work
that we do that I don't think
necessarily lends itself
to us doing our best work
and certainly not toward us
working with each other.
The other thing that
I think it's broken
is because we didn't
used to even think
about being on the New
York Times Bestseller list.
We didn't think about
having a show on Broadway.
So that now when people
ask you questions like,
aren't you hoping you'll
get a show on Broadway?
And I say I don't care.
I'm a working playwright.
I have plays all
around the country.
Broadway doesn't
mean anything to me.
Don't you think you want to have
a New York Times bestseller?
It's wonderful because you
can pay your rent for a year
and make your parents proud, but
it doesn't mean that now you're
a real writer.
You knew you were a writer
before you ever sold a book.
You told me you were a writer
when you were 16 years old.
So now that people are telling
you that, you don't take it
the same way like,
I never knew it
before the New
York Times told me.
You say back to
the New York Times
I told you all I was a writer,
which is a different thing.
[APPLAUSE]
So Pearl, you
talked about giants
like Bebe Moore Campbell,
Alice Walker, Maya Angelou.
Tayari, I'm curious to know if
you have current black women
writers that sort of helped
to sustain you as a writer,
as a woman, as a friend.
Well I went to
Spelman, so I do have
a different kind of
orientation to understanding
black women as mentors.
That's what I've
known from the start.
I didn't have to have kind of
moment of revelation for it.
But I do think that black
women have been helpful to me.
I literally ran into Jewell
Parker Rhodes in an elevator
like, oh, excuse me.
Like I ran into
her and she invited
me to come to Arizona State and
work with her to get my MFA.
And she took care of me.
I worked as her assistant
and she demonstrated to me
a way of living as a
writer that I had not
known before in those two
years that I was her assistant.
The first award I
ever received was
from the Hurston
Wright Foundation
which is run by Marita Golden.
So black women have
always been there.
When I published my
first book Nikki Giovanni
invited me to her
house for the weekend
to talk to me
about what it would
be like to be a public person.
And I was thinking, oh, I've
just written this one book.
I didn't think I was ever
going to be a person that
would need Nikki Giovanni's
helpful hints on the writing
life.
But I will say in the last
year I have done everything
because she said
to me it's coming.
You don't know it,
but it's coming.
And I didn't believe it,
but I was like yes ma'am
because she's Nikki Giovanni.
But she had me to her
house for a whole weekend.
I had my little overnight bag.
I was so nervous.
I was like, what am I
going to talk about?
We played Scrabble.
But there's always been that.
And also, though, every
generation in some ways
is living an unprecedented life.
And so your mentors can tell you
what it was like 20 years ago.
But every generation faces
completely new challenges.
So you have your
mentors that help you,
but then there's also
kind of figuring it out.
And I feel like one
thing I've really
been grateful for in my
relationship with Pearl
is that, Pearl, you're
always open to figuring out
this new challenge.
You don't say, well,
this is how we did it
and this is how it's done.
Like even negotiating
the internet,
what does that mean
to be a writer?
How do you negotiate
questions of privacy
and what really matters?
And the internet
makes it so hard
to stay out of other
people's business.
And the key, I think, to sanity
as a writer is like-- remember
when you were in grade school
and they would say keep
your eyes on your own paper?
Keep your eyes on
your own paper.
Stop looking at other
people's careers.
Look at your own.
But the internet has made that
an entirely different kind
of thing.
I mean, you've read
all of our letters.
Did you give them
all the letters?
Oh goodness.
I have to say that when
I was up in the library
and I saw that postcard
with my handwriting on it,
I was like, oh my goodness,
which one is that?
That was one of my favorite
items from the exhibit.
Because I would say we probably
exchanged 20 letters a year
at least.
Yeah.
So when I saw that my letters
were in the collection,
I was thinking it really
could be anything.
I have most of the more
recent ones, so I got you.
I got you.
So you both have been writing
for many years and you
have a distinct literary voice.
Are there any up and coming
writers that you're really
excited about?
Oh my goodness,
there are so many.
There's so many up
and coming writers.
I mean one thing that's
really exciting to me
is that there's
kind of a missing
in the generations of
black women writers.
When it came time for me to get
blurbs for my novel An American
Marriage, I realized
that there were
black women writers who are
say 10 years older than me--
I'll just tell you all I'm 47.
So the ones who would be like
in their late 50s, early 60s,
that whole generation
they're not
publishing the
way they once did.
Something was short
circuited and we've kind of
misplaced a lot of writers
that used to be active.
I didn't provide
blurbs for everyone,
but I would read the books
because this younger generation
would say they really wanted
a black woman to blurb
their book.
And there were not that many
who were actively publishing
who could blurb their book.
And so I was always
busy reading and I
would let any of
them call me and I
would talk to them for a
couple hours about what
it's going to be like to
have your first book out.
But now it's so many of them,
they could blurb each other.
They could give
each other advice.
And that has been
really exciting to see
that there are so many
up and coming writers
in all different genres.
That's another thing too.
There's so many different
ways of black women writers
doing their thing that
there isn't that pressure
to tell the one story.
So like in the world of
mystery we have Attica Locke.
I just adore her mysteries.
I really love The Turner
House by Angela Flournoy.
I really like the short stories
Heads of the Colored People
by Nafissa Thompson-Spires.
Spires.
Yes.
I really loved her book.
I love there's a collection
of short stories called Meet
Behind Mars by Renee Simms.
I mean I could
just go on and on.
I just love Danielle Evans.
Her book is called Before You
Suffocate Your Own Fool Self.
You must love that book.
So I mean I love that this
next generation, it's so big.
And it's funny though.
There's so many of them
and there's such a delight
in there being so many of them.
But then I do think that they
will not be quite as close knit
because I mean it's both
the pleasure of progress,
and also the other side
of it is that each of them
is not as unique and
special to the other
as you would in a smaller group.
But I think that also
gives them more freedom.
I mean I don't know.
Does this makes
sense if I say they
have the freedom that they don't
have to all like each other?
You know what I mean?
There is a freedom
in that I think.
Yes.
I think that's very true because
it's not so much that there was
a rule that you
had to like people,
but there were such
a small number of us
that when you went on tour,
when another black woman
writer lived in that town
and heard you were coming,
we went to find each other.
And we would always, do you
want to come back to my house
and eat?
What do you need?
Because we knew the person
was out there, usually
alone, not traveling with agents
and managers and all of that,
so that it was more
of a we're going
to surround you with sisterhood
on this journey that you're on.
But it is true.
It isn't necessary because
there's so many more of them
and they have so many
more support systems--
And it's sisterhood like
sisterhood is in real life, not
metaphorical sisterhood.
No.
I mean for real.
Yeah.
Sisterhood in real
life is complicated.
So yes, you would be
surrounded in sisterhood.
I would say we're
all like a family
and I mean that for
better and for worse.
That's right.
But the good parts
of that would be
after Bebe had given
me this great advice
and I had a bestseller
and I was on the road
and I was exhausted, I had been
on the road for three weeks
and I got to LA, which
is where she lived,
and she called me up and
said-- and we had never met.
We had just talked on the phone.
She said, OK, I'm going to come
and pick you up at the hotel
and bring you back to my house.
I know you need a
home cooked meal.
So I said, OK, that
would be great.
Because the book was doing well
they had me at the Four Seasons
in Beverly Hills.
So that was really fun
to see people coming back
from shopping trips with
just lots and lots of stuff.
But she said, OK, I'm going
to come and pick you up.
I said, fine.
I'll meet you out front.
She said I'm in a cherry
red Cadillac convertible.
And I laughed.
I thought she was kidding.
She cruised up in
front of my hotel
in a cherry red
Cadillac convertible.
I jumped in the car and we
headed off into the LA night
and I said we are
writers now for real.
We are really writers
because it's an adventure.
It's hard and it's
grueling being
on the road and all
of that, but it's
such a wonderful adventure.
I mean, wouldn't
you say that it is?
It's all the good stuff
and all the bad stuff,
but the adventure of it
is something that remains.
And you're in the
midst of a tour
so I probably shouldn't ask you.
I mean, I do think that the
most exciting thing to me
actually has--
I love meeting other writers
and it's very exciting
to meet people
you've only heard of,
and now you know them
and you can call them.
But to me the best part about
being a black woman writer,
a black woman
readers, are readers--
You probably don't even
remember this, Pearl.
We did this reading together.
This is about 15 years ago.
And I read, she read.
I was signing.
She had this long signing
line all around the corner
and I signed my few people
who were interested in me.
And this woman came
and she brought Pearl
this jewelry box
she had made and it
was full of all these
hand beaded earrings.
And she was showing Pearl the
earrings and she looked at me
and said, oh, you poor thing.
She said you don't
have any fans.
And she said Pearl, do you mind?
And she went in the jewelry
box and got this little pair
and said, here,
these are for you.
[LAUGHTER]
And I said thank you.
I put them on.
Because that's what you do.
And I thought that's the most
generous readers, the most
generous who would hand-make
all these earrings for her,
share some with little me.
I mean, when I
moved to New Jersey
I received a hand knitted
Afghan from one of my readers
who said it's really
cold up there.
I had a time when I was
in between contracts.
I couldn't get a
contract for my book.
I was in terrible
shape, but I always
knew that I had black women
readers who would write to me
and say hope the
book is going well.
We're looking forward to it.
So that even when the
publishers were telling me
there was no
audience for my work,
I knew there was an
audience for my work
because they had told me so.
And that has been
the thing that's
really unique because
being black publishing it's
hard to make the same amount of
sales as your white colleagues.
It's just racism pretty much.
You don't sell as many books.
But I feel that your readers
appreciate you so much.
None of your readers
take you for granted
and you don't take
them for granted.
So you have this connection.
So there's a program
called Book Scan.
This thing is the
bane of my existence.
They can put your
name in the book scan
and see how many books you sell.
So if you want to go
up for an opportunity,
they can just punch it in there.
Before Book Scan you used
to could just act successful
and people would take
your word for it.
But now they can actually
pull up the numbers.
So my book scan may not be the
same as my white colleagues,
but I feel that my heart and my
writing life with my readers,
I have twice the
life that they do.
Excellent.
Nice.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm sure you both have a
huge following of black women
readers here in Atlanta.
I know that my book club
reads you all quite often.
I'd like to shift
gears a bit and talk
about you both as writers.
So Pearl, you are a writer
and figure that synonymous
with the city of
Atlanta; and Tayari,
when the news broke that you
would be coming here to Emory,
it felt like a homecoming
that was sort of long overdue.
And Atlanta has loomed so
large in both of your works.
Can you talk a little bit
about what's special to you
about the city of
Atlanta as a writer?
Well, I think it's
interesting that people
are surprised that you can set
a bunch of books in Atlanta.
I mean I have six novels
that are set in Atlanta.
I have a number of plays
Because a lot of people
who live in New York think
there isn't really a real
life outside of New York.
If you're going to
write a real book
you have to write
about New York.
If you're going to
write a real book
you have to write
about New York.
Well I don't live in New York.
I live in southwest Atlanta.
So I don't even live
all over Atlanta.
I live in southwest
Atlanta, so that my books
are set in southwest
Atlanta because that's
the community I know.
And I always want to
write about what I know,
which isn't to say all
writers have to do that.
I mean some people can transport
themselves to someplace
they've never been.
And I admire that,
but I really want
to get it right by writing about
something that I know well.
And I know that I have
had people come to me
and talk to me about the
books as if they really
expect to run into these
people on the street, which
is a wonderful thing for me.
A woman came up to me--
I want to run into Blue.
I know.
People always looking
for Blue Hamilton.
Always looking for Blue.
A woman came up to me and
said, I love your new book--
and it was one of the novels.
I love your new book, but
you got something wrong.
And I said, well,
OK-- because that's
the other thing about our
readers, they will tell you.
I said, OK, what
did I get wrong?
And she said the
Krispy Kreme is not
across from the Marta Station.
The Krispy Kreme is
further down Cascade Road
because in between
the time I wrote
the book and the time
the book was published,
the Krispy Kreme moved from
where it was down the block.
And the woman was
highly indignant
that I had misplaced
the Krispy Kreme.
So I explained to her
the process of publishing
and that the reason was
the time that it took.
And I said, I swear
to you next book
I will make sure the Krispy
Kreme is in its right place.
And I did.
I put somebody in there
going through the drive thru
and talked about how the drive
thru was just the devil's work
because you could
get donuts so easily.
But I loved her for being so
protective of the neighborhood
that we both live in and
that we both love that she
wanted me to get it right.
If you're going to write
about our neighborhood then
write about our neighborhood.
Get it right.
So I've always found that
to be a tremendous level
of satisfaction to write about
the neighborhood where I live,
to write about people who could
inhabit those places where
I live.
So it's been wonderful for me
and it's always funny to me
that people who live in New York
will be surprised that people
outside of New York like us
can set a book in Atlanta
and it can actually be a
good and interesting book.
I mean I was living in New
York up until like about 10
minutes ago and I found
that when I was in New York
I would tell people
I was from Atlanta
and it would be kind
of confusing to them
because when you say
you're from the south
they act like you got to
Brooklyn on the Underground
Railroad.
[LAUGHTER]
And they expect you to
have this super tragic life
story because they don't
know how we live in Atlanta.
I mean I feel like Atlanta
has more opportunities for me
as a black woman than New York.
But they can't believe
that because just the way
that they've constructed
their identity
and their understanding
of politics.
And so when I
wrote my first book
about growing up in Atlanta
during the child murders,
I wanted to write
about it because I
felt like the generation
that grew up at that time,
that our experience
had been forgotten.
Even here at home that no
one really talked about it
and I wanted to write that as
a love letter to my generation
as a remembrance.
So I wrote that for that reason.
But then I kept setting
the books in Atlanta
because I feel like
one, it's what I know,
but also I feel
like there's a space
in southern literature,
the black urban southern
experience.
People think that
southern literature is
about grandmothers and mules.
I've never even seen
a mule in my life.
I wouldn't know one
if it walked in here.
And so I started kind
of self consciously
writing toward that.
And also I'm very
interested in the ideas
of the way black people
negotiate questions of class.
And I read somewhere that
they say the most people don't
know anyone that is from a
different class background
as they are.
But I feel that
with black people
we have so much class mobility
in a generation because
of civil rights.
My father literally
picked cotton as a boy
and he's in his 80s
now and he has a PhD.
So just imagine what the class
range of that is in the family,
and we have just
a lot of movement.
And so I always wanted
to write about that.
And I felt like the south,
Atlanta in particular,
gives a lot of space to talk
about black upward mobility,
downward mobility, all the
ways that we know each other.
And so that's why
I choose Atlanta,
and also I want to
write a book where
the people seem familiar to me.
I want to write a book
where the people feel
like they live on the page.
That they live in the
world, not on a page.
I mean that's just a
different style of writing.
But I want to feel like if
something were to happen,
the apocalypse were
to happen, that we
would leave our books behind and
people could see what happened.
That's very powerful, especially
as someone from the south
and definitely appreciating
you all depicting the south
in a certain way.
Basically everything that
you've said that there is life
here in the south
that's not rural.
Do you all consider
yourself southern writers?
I do now.
I didn't for a long time
because I grew up in Detroit.
So for a long time I was
one of those transplants
who would say I'm from Detroit.
I'm from Detroit.
I'm from Detroit because
that's where I grew up.
And then of course because
all the real Atlanta
people would never
let you forget
that you weren't from here.
It's like no, you've only
been here 10 years, 20 years,
30 years.
They still won't let
me be from Atlanta.
So for a long time southern
writer to me meant Faulkner.
It was not something
that I thought about
because I didn't
identify with the region.
I identified racially.
I identified as a black writer.
I grew up in a black
nationalist household
so that we were less focused
on the region we were living in
and more focused on
the race that we were.
So that it took me
a long time to get
my mind comfortable with
the idea of calling myself
a southern writer.
But I live in the south
and I write in the south
about a southern place.
So I don't think I can deny it.
I mean I think if we're
going to do definitions
I would have to call myself a
black woman, southern writer
feminist.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So it's kind of like, OK,
how many kinds of labels
can you have?
But I'm comfortable
with that one.
I guess that's fine.
I mean I'm a southern writer.
It's not even complicated.
But I am a member of the
Fellowship of Southern Writers,
which is an organization.
There are 50 southern writers
and they induct another--
they only bring in a new writer
if another writer passes away.
And I'm one of the few black
people in the Fellowship
of Southern Writers.
And I've always wanted to
be called a southern writer,
and up until very
recently I just was not.
I was called a black writer
because they will only
let you be one thing at a time.
And a lot of my white
Southern colleagues,
they are trying to
break out of that.
They feel like that's
a pigeonhole or a niche
for them to be called
a southern writer.
They want to break out and
I'm trying to break in.
But it is important for
me that black writers
identify as southern.
This is our home.
We have so much history
here in the south.
It's very specific to the south.
And I just hold it up and when
there's a southern writers
event and I'm not
invited, I'm mad.
As a matter of fact,
I was on the phone
today with a guy
from Time Magazine.
They had that
issue on the south.
He called me about
something else.
I was like, well, before
we go any further,
we need to talk about
why you didn't call me
about this southern thing.
And he said, oh, it was
by no means comprehensive.
I was like, obviously.
[LAUGHTER]
But he promised me I'll
be in the next one.
Excellent.
In closing, I'd like to bring
us back to where we started
with the concept of mentorship.
And I think that you all have
really dropped some gems for us
in terms of the advice that
you've received from a mentor.
But what advice might you
give to your younger self
about being a writer?
I would say don't worry so much.
But I would say that about
every area of my life, not just
writing.
But I was so intensely
focused on being a writer,
but I was also worried about
how I would make a living,
whether or not I
had anything to say,
whether or not the
boys would ever
move aside so that we girls
could have something to say.
All of those things that
I worried about a lot.
And I think that
the idea of being
able to relax into what you are
as early as you possibly can
is always something wonderful.
And you can't control that.
Sometime you can
know who you are
and relax into it
when you're 25.
Sometime you have
to be 70 to do it.
But whenever you
do it it's going
to be that moment when you say,
oh, this is what I'm doing.
So I think that
the biggest thing
would be not to worry
because I've always
been very disciplined.
I've always been able
to meet a deadline.
I've always found
opportunities and pursued
them and all of that.
So I think it's basically just
the relax and do your work.
Don't drive yourself crazy.
You'll be fine.
Thanks.
I think I would give myself
the advice, which actually she
gave me the advice, but
I would have given it
to myself before she had a
chance to give it to me, which
is that it's OK to quit things.
When I went to graduate
school I didn't
want to be in graduate school.
I only went to graduate
school to get a PhD because I
was being discouraged
from every side
from trying to be a writer
because they weren't my family
and some of my other
mentors-- everyone's
worried about how I was
going to make a living.
And so they said go get the PhD.
Go do that and you can do your
writing, whatever this is, you
can do that on the weekends.
And I took the--
what is that test?
--the GRE and I
made a good score so I
was given a fellowship
to go get this PhD.
I was 20 years old
and I was so unhappy.
It just wasn't what
I wanted to do.
And I wrote Pearl this long
letter about how unhappy I was
and how I had other plans
and I wanted to write a book,
maybe about the
Atlanta child murders.
I wrote her all this
long, long, long letter
and she sent me back a postcard
and she said leave that place.
[LAUGHTER]
It said something
like you can quit.
Nothing's going to happen.
It's your life.
And I said, really?
Because I had
always been told you
have to finish what you start.
And I quit, and guess what?
Nothing happened.
It was fine.
So I think I would have told
myself that earlier, that you
may feel like the responsibility
for yourself, for the race,
for everyone that's
on your shoulders.
But it's really not.
Do what you need to do
to make your life better.
And I remember that
because I remember
feeling like the responsible
thing for me to do
was to say stick
it out, and I knew
that Mack and Barbara would
kill me if I told you you should
drop out and all of that.
But it was like trying to
write the responsible letter
and then saying this woman
is a writer like you.
She's dying out there.
So that's why it was
down to the postcard.
So it was like, what do
you really want to say?
And all I really wanted to
say was leave there now.
Get on the plane, pack
your stuff, and come home.
Just imagine me reading
it and I start packing.
That's right.
Pack your stuff and come home.
Well, we're so glad
that you're home now.
Thank you both so much for
sharing this evening with us.
This has been so
lovely and getting
to know more about your
relationship to one another
and how black women
writers, either
in your own personal life
or ones that you've read
or your readers have impacted
your own work, is so amazing.
And I'm so honored to have
you all with us this evening.
Thank you.
So now what we are going
to do is actually give you
all the opportunity
to ask questions.
We'll take questions
from Facebook Live
and then we will
also take questions
from those of you that
are in the ballroom.
So there are two microphones
right here in the front.
So you can begin to line
up there for your question
so that we can take as
many questions as possible.
Please do take a few moments
to formulate your question.
Her microphone is not
here, so let's do this one.
All right.
Well, we're going to
start maybe on this side
where the microphone
is [CUTTING OUT]..
So I want to first
say thank you this.
I absolutely mean it.
I have been holding onto two
books for about seven years
because the publishing company
that I sent it to basically
told me that it wasn't
worth publishing.
So what do I do?
I don't even know
where to begin.
I've been having this
story for so long that I'd
like to present and I don't even
know where to begin with it.
Have you written
the book already?
Yes.
So you're looking for
a publisher basically?
Is that where I begin?
Do I look for an agent or
do I look for a publisher?
Do you have an agent?
I don't.
OK.
It's better to have an agent
before you have a publisher,
but those are real specific.
Can you just stop and talk to
me for a second afterward--
Sure.
--because you need all of that
in order to protect yourself,
or you can look at the whole
idea of self publishing,
which is much more possible
now than it used to be.
So let's talk a
little bit after.
OK, great.
Thank you.
And I appreciate you're
saying you needed this
because I needed this a lot.
I've been watching the hearings
all day and I think all of us
as Americans and as
people who believe
in freedom and as people
who believe in truth,
I think we have to think
deeply about what's
happening to our institutions.
I think we have to think
deeply about our responsibility
as American people.
And if you didn't see any
of that hearing today,
just look at a little bit of it.
Look at what the woman
who stepped forward
against all sanity to tell
the truth as a good citizen.
Look at what she had
to say and then look
at the response
of Republican men
on that committee who
had something to say.
Because as American
people-- and Tayari
will tell you how long it
took me to even call myself
an American person.
--but we have to think deeply
as Americans about what
that mess that went on today in
Washington means for all of us.
[APPLAUSE]
So we're going to take a
question from Facebook Live.
This is a question for
both you Pearl and Tayari.
What is your all time
favorite book or novel?
And we don't have to
say each other's books.
[LAUGHTER]
Not required.
It's like what book or novel is
speaking to me at the moment?
About five years ago I was
kind of obsessed with Tar Baby
by Toni Morrison.
And I think it's
because I was writing
a novel that was raising some
of the same questions with it.
And right now I'm writing
something about Ann Petry's The
Street.
And it was published
I want to say in '47.
She sold a million
copies and she's kind of
fallen off the radar.
She was the first
black women to sale--
this is a million
copies before Twitter.
There weren't even
as many people
in the country to buy
the million copies,
and she did this.
And I've been really
obsessed with her career
and that novel The Street.
Because it's hard to pick one--
I mean I have many
that I like, but I
think one that made a
big impression on me
was The Temple of My
Familiar by Alice Walker
because it was so not what I
expected from Alice Walker.
Which I've learned not to expect
anything from Alice Walker
because she's going
to give me what
she's supposed to give
me at that moment.
But that book was
so expansive and so
able to go beyond what
people had kind of put
in the box of this is what
black women writers are allowed
to write about.
She was writing
about reincarnation.
She was writing about all kinds
of things, a 500-year-old woman
walking through the book.
And it was just a
wonderful, amazing book.
So I would have to say
The Temple of My Familiar
is one that really
continues to be one
that I go back to just for the
pleasure of opening to any page
and saying, oh, I
remember that's the story
about the feathers.
Oh, I remember that's the
story about this and that.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a senior at Spelman College.
Oh, at Spelman.
Yeah.
I want to say thank you
so much for being here.
I love An American Marriage.
It's by far my favorite novel.
But I wanted to ask
as someone who's more
like comfortable with
academic and stiff writing,
how should I nurture my
creative writing skills?
Just practice.
Do you keep a journal?
I do it every day.
Are you stiff in your journal?
No.
But more so just like capturing.
I guess similar to what
you all talked about
and capturing the
city of Atlanta.
Like how do I capture stories?
I'm into sociology so I do a
lot of type of ethnographies.
So I want to know
how do I really tell
the stories of other people in
I guess like a free way that
is not just jaded or bias?
You're going to be
bias, and that's OK.
Your bias is your point of view.
And that's a good thing.
So I think that's one
thing, is don't try
to run from your point of view.
What is it they say?
It's not a bug, it's a feature?
Yeah.
That's what that is.
But just don't worry.
It sounds like you're worrying
about what someone else is
going to say about it.
You're critiquing it
as you're writing it.
Writing and publishing
are two different things.
Writing is where
you can be free.
It's just between you and
the page, and later on worry
about what someone
else is going to think.
Worry about an audience later.
But just write for
your own pleasure.
Write a story that
speaks to your heart,
and once you do that
it will be free.
It will not be
stiff and you just
worry about all that
other stuff later.
Thank you.
And eavesdrop on people.
Listen to people.
You want to write about Atlanta?
Go someplace in a public place
and sit and listen to people.
I mean that's a
great story you have
about in American Marriage.
But just listen to people
because not only will you
get great stories,
but you also will
be able to be more familiar with
the rhythms of how people talk.
Listen to a conversation
and then see
if you can reproduce it.
Listen to what people
are saying when
they're arguing
in a public place,
trying to keep
their voices down.
What did they say when they're
arguing in a public place
and don't care about
keeping their voices down?
But just listen to people.
Listen to what they say
and try to figure out
how much you can glean
from what they actually say
and then from the things
they're not saying
and put it in your journal.
Write it down.
Thank you.
Good evening.
I'm Dr. Karla Booker.
I'm former faculty at
Morehouse School of Medicine.
And I want to just
say I'm just moved.
I'm moved by the
warmth in the room
by the personal
relationship I feel
I have with you having
never met either one of you.
And I'm really curious
because I really
feel that there's something
about the mentorship
and the sisterhood and the
auntie and the mother/daughter
that is going on on
this stage that we
need to have in this country.
I'm a physician here in Atlanta.
I'm 55 years old, so on
the end of my career.
And so there were no
black female physicians,
and I was here in Atlanta at
Georgia Baptist or Atlanta
Medical Center
during my residency.
So I'm trying to
figure out, how is it
that we're in the
same generation
and that mentorship was not
there for me as a physician?
And I want to be able to
give it going forward.
So how is it that, what?
20 years ago?
30.
30 years ago that
you all had this
and have this warm powerful
humility that I just
feel like we want to
have as black women.
And I feel like
sometimes there's
this something that says,
yeah, it's mutually exclusive.
I can't have it and
you have it too.
And how can we do
that for ourselves
as black women and also to do
it for ourselves as Americans
and human beings?
Because that's the
end to all this stuff
you're talking about
that's going on today?
So I want to acknowledge that.
When I teach, I tell my
students when they find out
about opportunities, they'll
try to hoard an opportunity.
They'll find out
there's a fellowship
and they won't tell the
others because that'll lessen
their own chance of getting it.
And I have to tell
them that's OK.
You have to let the
others try, even if it
means that it could cost you.
I mean the students,
they know that the more
people who apply the lesser
your own chances of getting it.
That's just the truth.
So the reason you
share with others
is not that we can both
have it, because there
are going to be some
things we can't both have,
but that's not the point.
The point is that we can
all have the opportunity,
and that's what I think
is a thing to learn.
People are so afraid
of losing something,
but I don't think the answer is
to tell them they won't lose.
The answer is that
you might lose that,
but what you gain
from helping someone
is more valuable than
that thing you might lose.
Perfect.
I also think the
thing about mentoring
is that the word itself
sounds so formal.
And I'm sure that I've
played a mentoring role,
but the fact is I don't think
of myself as her mentor.
We're friends so that there's--
But she is my mentor though.
I feel like she just
kicked me out the nest.
No.
Never.
But I have run into lots
of talented young women
and I try to give them
the benefit of what
I can give them.
And then it's just
like in life and then
you meet somebody
who actually is
going to be a friend of yours.
So that of course the
mentoring will always go
on because I'll always be older,
but it's like there's things
that you know and have
experience that I haven't.
I mean I can't even figure
out the password on my phone.
So it's just the whole idea
of talking about social media
and all of that.
So I think if you're trying
to pass on some of what
you longed for and didn't get--
don't think of it so much in the
abstract as a mentoring thing.
Find a young woman that
you like and then tell her
what you know.
Take her out to
have a cup of tea
or a glass of wine or
whatever and talk about things
because I don't think
it becomes after a while
a formal thing of, OK, now
you're home from your trip.
How did it go and I'll tell
you how I'm feeling about it.
It's kind of like let's
go have dinner and tell me
how it's going.
So find somebody that you like
and tell them what you know.
Fabulous.
Thank you so much.
Hi.
I'm Carolyn Jackson, and I
write for a couple of blogs
that I'm going to
plug in a little bit.
But in those groups that I've
worked with, a couple of times
it'll come up, who's
your favorite author?
So they don't really like
to ask me that anymore
because they knew I'm going
to say Pearl [INAUDIBLE]..
What's your favorite book?
What Looks Like Crazy
on an Ordinary Day?
So who knows how many
books I've sold for you.
Thank you.
Just simply buy every single
time they ask me that.
I plug you all the time.
So here's my question.
The book cover,
the original, which
I would love to have had you
autograph that particular one,
but I bought a new one, that you
can autograph that one for me.
What was the
inspiration with that?
The book caught my
eye, one, because Oprah
told me to read it, and then,
two, the cover was so unique.
What was the
inspiration behind that?
And then here's my
part two question.
Can I have Blue and is Ava
your favorite character?
Because she's actually
my favorite hero.
Is she my favorite--
Ava Johnson.
Ava Johnson is my
favorite shero.
And so those are all
my questions for you.
OK, great.
So the first question
is about the cover,
the cover of the first
edition where she's
lassoing the moon or something?
Absolutely.
What was the
inspiration behind that?
Totally not my choice.
Didn't have any input
into that at all,
and actually didn't
like that color at all.
But people have liked it a lot.
So I was wrong because
people did embrace it.
Yeah.
So oftentimes the
author doesn't have
much to say about the
cover of the book.
And that was their
design, not mine.
But it was all right.
It did fine and people liked it.
So it was fine.
And what'd you ask
me about the other--
Shero.
About?
Like my favorite shero?
Is Ava my favorite one?
Of all the women that
I've written about?
I can't really pick like that.
I love Ava so much,
but I also love
some of the other women
who have done other things.
I love the women in my play.
So that's kind of like
picking among your kids.
So I love them all.
I'd let them all
stay in that circle.
And one last one for Tayari.
What's your inspiration
for writing?
Your inspiration for writing?
In general?
Yes.
Oh.
It really varies.
I mean it varies with my mood.
I think consistently the
inspiration is always
to try to figure out an answer
to a question that's bothering
me in my own life and I then
I use the stories to try
to work it out.
But I don't write books
about people I know.
Sometimes people say, who
are these people really?
And I'm like they're
actually not anyone.
They think I'm lying, but
they really are imaginary.
But the questions
that they raise
tend to come from my own life.
I'd like to prattle
around in your head.
OK.
Thank you so much.
So we are going to take one
final question over here
on this side.
Good evening.
I just want to seize the
opportunity to say how--
I can kind of feel your
kind is coming for--
you probably don't remember me.
But my mother had passed
away and I met you
at the Nordan Juice
Bar and I had told you
about all I wanted was my
mother's letters my father had
written her from World War II.
And he must have written
something provocative
and he would say I
can't wait to get home
and then he'd cut it out.
So there was this letter
with all these holes in it.
And so you said, you know
that's a book, don't you?
And I said, it is?
And you said I'm
going on book tour.
Write something and when
I get back I'll help you.
So I used to see
you out and I'd hide
because I hadn't
written anything
and you said I'm not going
to bug you about writing.
If you want to
write I'll help you.
And I just thought
that was so kind.
And then one time you
said the material--
Do you mind add going for
it with your question?
I just wanted to thank
her for being kind
and I'd never got started.
But since I saw how
you mentored her
I really would take the
opportunity to write.
It's been very inspiring to me.
Thank you.